the baby ain't got no teeth what am I
gonna do don't slurp it up oh hi there
my name's Emily and my name is Joyce hey
my name is Q and I'm Matt as far as we
know we're adults I think we're
definitely adults yeah
and we're giggling today we're gonna be
eating baby food baby and I don't
remember eating it so I don't I don't
know how I feel about I think I ate it
in high school like in home at class
when we learned about babies okay yeah I
was gonna say why would you eat baby
food in high school that's just that's
what the cool kids do how many shoes get
into it just do it more we think about
it the more isn't gonna get that's true
that's true it's my favorite one this is
banana it's very smooth so if anyone has
a texture problem this might be food for
you
applesauce is basically baby food
already right like I can do that oh my
god this one's so good yeah yeah so see
now what they need to do here mm-hmm
is any different this bad baby on the
shelves right next to like da wall it's
gonna sound really lazy but this is some
kind of food I like cuz I don't have to
chew they put this in a blender with a
little like a shot of vodka yeah and
then just like well it's really it's
really good I think people are scared
mm-hmm they're scared to say that babies
have some slammin meals
this isn't baby food is it a Doku need
this any time bro business nap the tree
Oh beef and gravy I got chicken ham and
gravy
my eyes are watering I'm my body's
preparing oh that's got a smell nope oh
god I'm scared
get me a napkin I'm gonna barf like dog
food whoa
mine smells a little bit
oh wow Alice however I'm so confident to
like let the throw-up in like a medicine
I'm really like sweating my hands are
sweating over there sweating just come
on you know what there's times in your
life we just gotta [ __ ] your food it
literally tastes like someone shoot it
up frozen yeah
yeah did you like yours no it's really
dry
oh my god I never want to look at this
again I never want to think about this
again I will never feed this to my child
they can be vegetarian yeah oh there I
might be vegetarian this I don't like
chicken
at all I don't care fried chicken
grilled chicken chicken teriyaki take it
with you the thing is you thought you're
gonna poop after beef we're really gonna
poop out the food honestly I'm time
excited to poop at this point get that
beef to yourself I'm already like
nervous about the color of those kind of
like barbecue sauce in the pack not
gonna lie we're the Nuggets hmm
I mean if I had a baby and I'm like the
sweet treat I think this was a dessert
some whipped cream on it so like the
baby at first is gonna be like oh my god
yeah the prune baby food makes me feel
like I'm 45 years old I'm trying to get
my groove back like I'm ready for the
world
you empress thank you these are your
prunes well well we did it we did it
it's done
we only almost vomited it turns out like
the savory baby food is absolutely as
disgusting as you think if I was a
parent I would never give my kids the
meat mm-hmm soon as I ate that beef my
digestive tract started moving in ways I
haven't felt it moving you need to know
what you're feeding your kids because
most people probably just grab this off
the show yeah oh yeah they say it's good
if I put in my baby's mouth it's nobody
our baby spitting up everywhere we
obviously I think like this baby food
I've just combined two flavors because
I'm a genius it kind of looks like like
a dessert you can buy a pack of these
and feed yourself
I mean I'm going to go to the store
later obviously kids in the future or
whatever but like adults in the one with
money exactly fine
[Music]